une ancienne prophétie avait prédit
qu'un chevalier surgi du néant viendrait
libérer ses terres
ainsi c'est toi quillan qui a été
désigné pour ramener le trésor en lieu
sûr
méfie-toi son pouvoir dépasse
l'imagination
et nombreux sont les ennemis qui le
convoite rond
sir jeu doit rallier au plus vite le
royaume d'espagne nous prendrons la
route à l'aube avec mes hommes puis
emmènera quelqu'un avec toi une femme
une princesse vikings
clients un mal étrange route sur l'autre
les villages sont désertés les
populations terrorisées des forces
hostiles recherche le crâne
j'ignore la princesse sigrid a été
enlevé ils vont le regretter
quoi qu'il advienne je ramènerai le
saint chrême